I think numbers don't just percolate
through mathematics and physics and
chemistry ins and Sciences but they're
in everything around us so poetry is an
extreme form of word play in which
numbers dictate form and structure which
give more beauty to it
the number is 1414 because I want to
recite to you Brady
a love sonnet which has 14 lines these
14 lines are structured to come in
groups of 4 4 4 & 2 and they actually
have to go all the way through in a
particular structure using what I called
I am big pentameter z' which means that
they go da da da da da da da da the da
in each line so there is a rhythm of 10
in each line which imposes an enormous
constraint on a poet trying to fit these
the da da da da Das into this rigid
structure of 14 lines so the one I want
to talk about is sonnet 18 shall I
compare thee to a summers day thou art
more lovely and more temperate rough
winds do shake the Darling Buds of May
and summers lease have all too short a
date sometime too hot the eye of heaven
shines and often is his gold complexion
dimmed and every fair from fair sometime
declines by chance or nature's changing
course untrimmed but thy eternal summer
shall not fade nor lose possession of
that fair thou owest
nor shall death brag thou wand'rest in
his shade when in eternal lines to time
thou grow'st so long as men can breathe
or eyes can see so long lives this and
this gives life to thee Shakespeare
wrote these poems in the form of a
sonnet it's called a Shakespearean
sonnet and they were love poems too well
I think it was written either for his
patron so they could pass it on to their
girlfriends or to his boyfriends who
knows the numbers were this beat of
iobit pentameters ten syllables and at
the end you have a rhyme so in the first
line you have shall I compare thee to a
summers day thou art more lovely and
more temperate may date which rhymes
with temperate joins dimmed declines
untrimmed
fade oast shade ro s see thee so the
last two lines don't rhyme every other
one they have to rhyme with each other
so this is a summary and a sudden
emphasis through the rhythm and through
the words of the whole meaning of the
poem it's rigidly structured to have
these rhymes all the way through it to
have these beats running all the way
through it the numbers purely adding a
straitjacket to constrain the poet or
other numbers helping the poet to add
beauty that's of deep question which you
just thought up and I have no idea which
way it's the chicken which comes first
the chicken or the egg
I think Shakespeare was so fluent in all
aspects of wordplay that he could turn
his hand to anything and it was almost
as though he took the old Plutarch
version of sonnets turned it slightly
differently and showed he could write
150 odd of these things at will knocking
off ten at a time because he was so
fluent and I don't think the numbers
were a constraint to him at all but to
any other poet modern poets they would
find it incredibly difficult Shakespeare
had an enormous vocabulary much bigger
than scholarly people of these days it
was as though he had words from all
sorts of language mixed in then how
somebody from Stratford could have such
a vocab Ria's beyond me and it's because
of that that he found such fluency we
got married in 72 August the 12th and
that's a photo a year later and we were
in stratford-on-avon on a beautiful
sunny day and my wife was wearing a
flowery dress and she looked absolutely
beautiful in front of this cottage which
was Anne Hathaway's cottage
Shakespeare's wife now don't think that
Shakespeare wrote sonnets for his wife
it's not that sort of romantic lives
when they had it was more well he left
her for example and I've never left my
wife for any length of time
you